nous saurions quand ils viennent
parce que c'est à chaque saison et il n'y a
pas vraiment beaucoup d'hommes qui ne sont pas de votre
famille dans le Nord donc ces hommes viendraient
et ils apporteraient de l'alcool et puis
nous serions restés et nous nous sentirions comme wow
il m'a choisi  est-ce qu'ils viennent vous chercher
parfois ils n'attendent même pas d'aller à
la caravane
c'est dégoûtant mais maintenant si les filles peuvent
savoir que ce n'est pas bien, elles devraient
porter plainte ou elles devraient faire savoir aux gens
que ces gens font qu'il y
a une issue  vraiment mais ce n'est pas toujours
disponible pour tout le monde
et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
rencontré mon amie, elle était infirmière à
salaire, elle a commencé à me faire comprendre que
ce n'était pas bien, cela ne me dérange pas si je vais
être jugé ou si je  Je vais être
méprisé J'ai fait ça pour protéger nos enfants
ou nos jeunes filles et pour éviter la
même chose qui est arrivée à beaucoup d'entre nous